[Music]
due to the pandemic the long border
between the u.s and canada remains
closed to non-essential travel
but essential does describe the work of
a small army of canadian health care
workers
every day they cross into the u.s to
care for american patients in michigan
hospitals
and during covid some got infected
themselves in canada there's been a push
back from people who fear these health
care workers could bring the virus back
home
but adriana diaz spoke with two nurses
who say despite those challenges
they wouldn't have it any other way
detroit nurse brent gale's commute
typically starts at 6 a.m
and in another country i cross the
international border every day
so when someone here says they were late
because of traffic i'm like i came from
another country
he works at saint mary mercy livonia
hospital in metro detroit
but lives across the detroit river in
windsor
canada we are on riverside drive in
windsor ontario looking at detroit
at least 1500 canadians work in
healthcare in michigan
some drawn by more job opportunities do
your patients realize
how many canadian nurses there are
working here in detroit
no i don't think they do but uh they
tease and joke that you know
i'll say something it'll be a turn of
phrase and then oh you're canadian
so you get that you say a boat or
something like that apparently i do
this small army of canadians have risked
their lives
especially in the spring of 2020 when
covid
raged in the u.s and there were more
daily copa deaths in michigan
than in all of canada it sucked it was
it
it was really bad you'd see the wave
coming and you're like okay we survived
it and then that next wave was coming
again before you could catch your breath
i just remember thinking like what is
going on like we're running out of
ventilators like
everybody needs to be intubated
canadian lindsay lafleur has been an er
nurse at detroit's henry ford hospital
for nearly five
years she says last spring's surge is
still
vivid i just remember standing in the
middle of the department and just
looking around like
dumbfounded and sad it must have been
pretty overwhelming
i cried a lot yeah parker said good
morning
that kovit's worst in detroit she had a
newborn at home in canada
and considered walking away from nursing
how nervous were you about your baby
i was really nervous she was really
young so we had her sleeping
in a pack and play in our room and i was
sleeping in her room in a tent
because i wanted to like conceal myself
somehow
so why do you do it why do you continue
to come
over the international border to work
here in detroit with covet patients
i love working here i love detroit i
love the hospital that i work for
i love the people that i work with you
like detroiters i like detroiters
yeah it's not it's not a border it's
just a line we
cross and we're the same people you know
and i just think it would have been
horribly cowardly to yeah to abandon my
american cousins
but back home in canada there was some
resistance to their cross-border work
there was sort of a stigma attached to
it a stigma a little bit you know you're
carrying the disease back and forth
there was a call in our local paper to
have us
you know stop being allowed to go back
and forth across the border
i was feeling the stress from the
community people were like you know we
thank you for all that you do but at the
same time like don't come near me
both did contract covid gail when a
patient's intubation tube came loose
lefleur thinks she may have gotten it in
windsor luckily her daughter did not
they recovered and remain committed as
ever
handsome wow you're awesome
stop it you're making me blessed still
treating their patients with a smile
there's this perception of canadians you
know the canadian nice
stereotype yeah is that real and does
that help you at work
i think it's more politeness than nice
and it does help
and we have patients come back all the
time oh i'm looking for the big bald
canadian
here the two sides of the river are one
community
and the nurses protect their own like
this is our big deal you know this is
our burning building this is what we run
to
and what we've been trained for like our
moment to shine for cbs this morning
saturday
adriana diaz detroit i grew up just a
few miles from the canadian border so i
know how close that relationship
is and how frustrating it's been for so
many that the border has been closed
for so long but the work that they're
doing there is just
remarkable i love how he said it's just
a line we crossed they're my they're
yeah
they're our cousins right yeah and you
see the personal sacrifice you're
reminded of these health care workers
personal sacrifices even as they care
for others still doing it today
still doing day in and day out well
thank you so much
adriana